[SPEAKER_04]: Second of Walesun at 11.15 p.m. Paul is sitting in the barracks main command center when the sergeant brings in four individuals that look like Marines.
[SPEAKER_04]: Basically, the sergeant comes in and says, Prince, here are four men from the Southern Garrison reporting to you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_05]: Paul?
[SPEAKER_05]: Which one of you is the gouge that I've heard about?
[SPEAKER_00]: I step forward.
[SPEAKER_00]: What's up?
[SPEAKER_00]: It's me.
[SPEAKER_00]: Hello.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've heard a lot about you.
[SPEAKER_00]: I've not heard a lot about you, unfortunately, but I'm glad you're safe.
[SPEAKER_05]: Doesn't matter.
[SPEAKER_05]: Anyways, how was your journey from, what town did you guys come from?
[SPEAKER_05]: The south?
[SPEAKER_05]: South Beacon.
[SPEAKER_05]: Was that...
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, things are not well here.
[SPEAKER_00]: As we witnessed on the landing there, so we've got that under control.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's commanding.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's commanded the sergeant there and got them all set up.
[SPEAKER_05]: And what is your name?
[SPEAKER_05]: Tyrus.
[SPEAKER_05]: And I meet you.
[SPEAKER_05]: Huge.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: We traveled in and there was no, um, we had no detection coming in, no trouble coming in through the woods, through the wilderness.
[SPEAKER_02]: We didn't go to the coastline because I saw down in the water several sharks and hogging.
[SPEAKER_02]: Merrick, I was sent by Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Merrick, good to meet you.
[SPEAKER_01]: I am Paul Rivero.
[SPEAKER_01]: If you know me or not, I am of nobility to Lord Jeon and nephew of Lord Jamis.
[SPEAKER_01]: Or, did I get that right?
[SPEAKER_01]: No, nephew to Lord Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Nephew to Lord Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Prince Jeon.
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm sure you know the situation here.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, we don't.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: Well, the Sahaugin have
[SPEAKER_01]: Surrounded us, there's not much else to go around, and we have reasonably that there is at least 300 to 250 hobgoblins around on this island alone.
[SPEAKER_01]: And we have devised a plan we can clean, enjoy, and what was the captain's name?
[SPEAKER_04]: The captain?
[SPEAKER_04]: Which one?
[SPEAKER_05]: The sergeant?
[SPEAKER_05]: No, the captain of the barracks.
[SPEAKER_04]: Oh, well, he's the sergeant.
[SPEAKER_04]: The commander.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Steve.
[SPEAKER_05]: Whatever.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, is that Steve?
[SPEAKER_05]: His name's Steve, okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: So we came in on...
[SPEAKER_05]: Right here is where you guys came in.
[SPEAKER_05]: We saw you... Yeah, we came in on this dock.
[SPEAKER_05]: The ship is gone.
[SPEAKER_05]: 200 Marines, they're gone.
[SPEAKER_05]: No more.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lost.
[SPEAKER_03]: So we came in and landed here.
[SPEAKER_03]: We took over this tower.
[SPEAKER_03]: The lighthouse is still manned by hobgoblins and the barracks are still manned by hobgoblins.
[SPEAKER_03]: We have about...
[SPEAKER_03]: I think about...
[SPEAKER_03]: Twenty was left.
[SPEAKER_03]: Twenty-five guys.
[SPEAKER_03]: Twenty-five guys that were left here.
[SPEAKER_01]: You guys dropped with, like, what, thirty Marines?
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, we lost a couple, but we have about at least twenty that are holding this tower along with my sergeant.
[SPEAKER_03]: And we can signal to him, if we need to, they're just going to hold this position for the moment and ward off ships.
[SPEAKER_03]: That should be fine, yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then so, as far as the...
[SPEAKER_03]: The helm.
[SPEAKER_00]: Do you have any information on that?
[SPEAKER_03]: I do.
[SPEAKER_01]: I do have some information about that.
[SPEAKER_01]: How many Marines are we strong at the barracks?
[SPEAKER_01]: 170 now.
[SPEAKER_01]: Me and Jude and the captain have been talking and we have learned a couple of things.
[SPEAKER_01]: And there's a couple of ways we could do this.
[SPEAKER_01]: The most simplest and least optional.
[SPEAKER_01]: Roman, what are you doing?
[SPEAKER_01]: Stealth.
[SPEAKER_01]: Oh.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Are you sneaking on us for?
[SPEAKER_05]: I already snuck up.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, you can do whatever you want.
[SPEAKER_05]: That's good.
[SPEAKER_01]: We have devised up a couple plans.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of the plans is to just sit tight, wait a day or two at most for reinforcements, but the only problem with that being is that there are other ships, merchants, just other regular ships that would pass through here that the Sakagin might get to, and I'm not too fond of that.
[SPEAKER_01]: One of the other ideas is
[SPEAKER_01]: We launch an attack with a hundred or so marines as a diversion for us, Jude and the five of us, to get over these walls.
[SPEAKER_01]: He can levitate us up one by one and we can get over through kind of the back
[SPEAKER_01]: Inside, and we can do that.
[SPEAKER_01]: It's a little risky, though, as if we do get spotted.
[SPEAKER_01]: And I have made up costumes for us, so we can at least... A hobgoblin will have to look twice at us.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: The other plan, which is a lot more riskier, but could benefit a lot more, we have been told that there is a cavern on the side of this...
[SPEAKER_01]: There's a wall to the ocean that goes under the helm, and supposedly there's a backway entrance in.
[SPEAKER_01]: No idea where it goes, what doors it connects to, or if it's even, like, we don't even know where it is.
[SPEAKER_01]: We just know it exists.
[SPEAKER_04]: Does anybody know where it exists?
[SPEAKER_04]: Nobody.
[SPEAKER_04]: Am I familiar with those routes?
[SPEAKER_04]: You heard the rumor that that exists.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you know that it has to be on this side.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: On the coast, though.
[SPEAKER_03]: On the coastline.
[SPEAKER_01]: The only problem with that is the sahaugin might tear us up.
[SPEAKER_01]: Those are the things that we have devised, me and Jude.
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there any way for us to signal if we do choose to go the underground way?
[SPEAKER_02]: I think costumes are still going to be... Oh, costumes are going to come with us.
[SPEAKER_05]: Regardless.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yep.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yes!
[SPEAKER_02]: Is there any way to signal to the tower that we are in danger or need people to come towards us?
[SPEAKER_02]: Any type of backup?
[SPEAKER_01]: None that I can think of.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, to be honest, if we were going to do this, I would still have the Marines attack with a diversion just so they can buy us time, but even then, like...
[SPEAKER_01]: We're going to be going in with just us, and the smaller the group the better, but if we get caught with our pants down, we're done.
[SPEAKER_01]: If we do do this, I believe we should move in night.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, it's already nighttime, isn't it?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yeah, I think we should move sooner or later.
[SPEAKER_01]: No, yeah, we were going to move preferably within the hour.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_00]: I, depending on what the elf says, I'm down with this.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'd rather use stealth and kind of sneak in and try to
[SPEAKER_03]: Go over the wall, though, and face it all.
[SPEAKER_03]: Really, we boiled it down to two choices.
[SPEAKER_03]: We're not going to wait.
[SPEAKER_03]: We boiled it down to two choices.
[SPEAKER_03]: Either A, we sneak along this path and try to find the cave entrance.
[SPEAKER_03]: They attack the diversion, trying to lead the hobgoblins out and at least give us a chance, which I do think could work.
[SPEAKER_03]: Are there any other exits out of this here except over the wall, out the back of this?
[SPEAKER_03]: Do I know that?
[SPEAKER_04]: You know it.
[SPEAKER_04]: There's a south door, I believe, right?
[SPEAKER_04]: The only entrance to the helm is the gatehouse here.
[SPEAKER_03]: The building, where we're at right now, is there another exit?
[SPEAKER_04]: You could definitely get out that way and sneak that way.
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, absolutely.
[SPEAKER_03]: We send the diversion out, we sneak out, and then the only two choices that we have is either A, he levitates us over the wall here, or B, we find the hidden entrance to run aside.
[SPEAKER_01]: I personally kind of like going over the wall just because we don't have to worry about the sahaugin, just because they're going to
[SPEAKER_01]: If we can get to the wall undetected, that's the first step.
[SPEAKER_05]: And from there, Merrick and I can...
[SPEAKER_00]: See if we can find the entrance going that direction.
[SPEAKER_00]: You should be able to tell whether or not you've got Sahaugin out there.
[SPEAKER_02]: I'm very familiar with the coastline, so the way we came in is I kind of led the pack searching out first, making sure everything was okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: We can go out the back, look for, and I'm familiar with these coastlines really well.
[SPEAKER_02]: Go out the back and if I see sahaugin, I can cast some fog to distract either so they can't see us and we can go back or keep moving forward.
[SPEAKER_02]: Where's the elf?
[SPEAKER_04]: What's that?
[SPEAKER_04]: You can cast that multiple times?
[SPEAKER_04]: He can cast it as many times as he has spell slides.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's not like he used components and they're gone and he's gotta come up.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where's the elf?
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: If he doesn't have components it doesn't work but it's a feather.
[SPEAKER_01]: Who's this elf we keep hearing about?
[SPEAKER_05]: His name is Jude.
[SPEAKER_01]: I believe he is resting right now.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know when he'll be back.
[SPEAKER_01]: Probably soon, though, I can assume.
[SPEAKER_00]: Actually, I wouldn't mind.
[SPEAKER_02]: I vote going through the cavern.
[SPEAKER_02]: Can I peel away and see if I can find you?
[SPEAKER_04]: Let me go get the L real quick.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay, so here's the deal.
[SPEAKER_04]: The elf is trancing, but if you want to take Gouge to Jude, you can do that.
[SPEAKER_00]: If you know where he's at, I'd like to speak to him briefly.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's in the middle of a... Of trancing.
[SPEAKER_05]: Trancing, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Maybe we should devise a plan.
[SPEAKER_05]: Okay, well, it's like an elf thing.
[SPEAKER_05]: Meditation of some sort.
[SPEAKER_05]: He's trying to get his spell slots back.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'm trying to say that without actually saying that.
[SPEAKER_05]: All right.
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, we're probably going to need that more than anything.
[SPEAKER_04]: So this is the thing.
[SPEAKER_04]: It is 11 p.m. You know Jude is probably going to take four, three, four hours to get all his spell slots back.
[SPEAKER_04]: Are you going to be willing to wait until 3 a.m. in the morning?
[SPEAKER_04]: 3 in the morning?
[SPEAKER_03]: That's going to give us like what, two hours of darkness at that point?
[SPEAKER_03]: Two or three.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then it's going to take us, just looking from here, it's going to be an hour to get to the wall.
[SPEAKER_03]: Nah, I don't want to wait.
[SPEAKER_03]: I don't want to wait here.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah, I want to wait here.
[SPEAKER_02]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_02]: Anybody know?
[SPEAKER_04]: Can Sahaugin see it late?
[SPEAKER_04]: Do a Arcana.
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, it's not.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's an Arcana check.
[SPEAKER_04]: No, it's not Arcana.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's Insight.
[SPEAKER_04]: And you get Expertise with this.
[SPEAKER_04]: Actually, no, not Expertise.
[SPEAKER_04]: It is Advantage.
[SPEAKER_04]: So you roll 220 for knowledge about this.
[SPEAKER_04]: Four.
[SPEAKER_04]: And, roll again.
[SPEAKER_02]: Twenty.
[SPEAKER_04]: They have Dark Pigeon.
[SPEAKER_02]: Yeah, they can see in the dark.
[SPEAKER_02]: My fog might help though.
[SPEAKER_02]: If me and him go first to scout out the area, I don't want to travel as just a big clunky pack full time.
[SPEAKER_03]: So the Oak is the only one that can see them at night though?
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah, and it's within, shit, I think it's only 60, 120 feet?
[SPEAKER_00]: 60 feet.
[SPEAKER_00]: 60 feet?
[SPEAKER_00]: So is that same with dark?
[SPEAKER_00]: Is their vision the same as the elf's vision, or can they see, are they even sharper, do you know?
[SPEAKER_00]: Can they see even further?
[SPEAKER_00]: Not the same.
[SPEAKER_00]: Roughly the same.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, that's not really that far.
[SPEAKER_00]: I mean, if we stay up above, you said they can't come onto the land too far just to...
[SPEAKER_05]: Briefly?
[SPEAKER_05]: They can be on the land for like 30 minutes.
[SPEAKER_05]: Longer even.
[SPEAKER_05]: They prefer not to travel.
[SPEAKER_00]: But they hate being on land.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so they're most likely post-guard down there.
[SPEAKER_00]: There might be some hobgoblins or something.
[SPEAKER_00]: I'm not sure.
[SPEAKER_00]: Potentially.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, we're gonna go into Skye as well.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's true.
[SPEAKER_00]: So, I don't know if we should sneak up ahead.
[SPEAKER_01]: The helm probably has
[SPEAKER_01]: 200, 250 at least hobgoblins in it.
[SPEAKER_01]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_01]: But we've been able to gather.
[SPEAKER_00]: And those will probably see the same type of vision.
[SPEAKER_02]: But if we send out the garrison to do an attack distraction, that's going to buy us some time to go around.
[SPEAKER_00]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's true, that's true.
[SPEAKER_00]: And then once we get inside, what are we going to do then?
[SPEAKER_00]: So, our mission once we get inside is to locate and find, if we can, Lord Fairwind.
[SPEAKER_03]: Lord Farrowind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you're signaling back to R?
[SPEAKER_00]: That we made it safe.
[SPEAKER_03]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_03]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_03]: And then what?
[SPEAKER_03]: We locate him and then what?
[SPEAKER_05]: Well, depends on the situation.
[SPEAKER_01]: If he's dead, then we...
[SPEAKER_01]: Depends on the situation, we try and get out of there, if we can, or take the home.
[SPEAKER_01]: I don't know.
[SPEAKER_00]: Who are you looking for?
[SPEAKER_00]: We're looking for Lord Farrowind.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_04]: Lord Farrowind, this is a sergeant.
[SPEAKER_04]: Steve?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yeah, Steve?
[SPEAKER_04]: He can bring up the enchantment that protects Helm Island from the fog.
[SPEAKER_00]: That's right.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay, so either one, he's dead, two, he's captured and can't do it, or three,
[SPEAKER_00]: He's not on our side anymore.
[SPEAKER_00]: But if we, yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: But there's reason to believe that he's locked up in a safe room with his guards.
[SPEAKER_03]: So the deal is that if he's locked up with his guards, anybody know this helm well enough to know where that might be?
[SPEAKER_05]: Fifteen plus, you realize this is one of fair wins.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, no, I mean if it's a safe room.
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh, okay.
[SPEAKER_05]: Are you asking me, like, if we know the innards of the helm?
[SPEAKER_00]: You know, spell casters can change the minds of people.
[SPEAKER_00]: There's a possibility.
[SPEAKER_00]: He's under some type of control.
[SPEAKER_04]: Fairwind is no spellcaster, but he does have the enchantment for Helm Island protecting him.
[SPEAKER_04]: He does, but I don't know who's over there who might have him.
[SPEAKER_04]: Adrian, do we have like a map or a... Ah, you think he's enchanted?
[SPEAKER_04]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_04]: Wait.
[SPEAKER_04]: Ah, that's possible.
[SPEAKER_05]: Yeah.
[SPEAKER_05]: Do we have a blueprint of the helmet?
[SPEAKER_05]: Bad, bad.
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_05]: We don't, okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: We need to be very weary that there is something going on at this island that I've never seen before, magic-wise.
[SPEAKER_00]: Steve does know it, and Merrick knows it.
[SPEAKER_00]: Oh, you know the way... Oh, that's right, you've been here many times.
[SPEAKER_00]: You know the island and the helmet.
[SPEAKER_00]: Inside here, inside them.
[SPEAKER_02]: Oh, I know the insides, yes.
[SPEAKER_02]: I've never gone through the tunnels, and, you know, this isn't a time, you know,
[SPEAKER_02]: Necessarily to adventure, but I am very curious on finding these things.
[SPEAKER_02]: Maybe a bad time, but, you know, we'll find out.
[SPEAKER_00]: Well, if we can come in underneath and nobody knows about it, this is by far the past.
[SPEAKER_03]: So then if they were keeping him, do we know where he might be, his safe room, or do you know where that would be in the castle?
[SPEAKER_03]: That would be direct entry into the castle.
[SPEAKER_04]: So, this is what I believe.
[SPEAKER_04]: I've told Paul and I've told Jude that he may be in the sanctuary, which is the most defended part of the keep.
[SPEAKER_04]: In fact, only the admiralty is allowed in there.
[SPEAKER_04]: It's behind most defenses.
[SPEAKER_04]: The barracks are separated from the rest of the helm by the tower.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do I have, um, do I have keys to these keeps, any doors or anything?
[SPEAKER_02]: No.
[SPEAKER_02]: Do you use Steve?
[SPEAKER_04]: Steve!
[SPEAKER_04]: Steve, come on.
[SPEAKER_04]: I have no keys.
[SPEAKER_04]: I'm not, I'm not, I'm not the master of the health.
[SPEAKER_04]: Where's the key, man?
[SPEAKER_05]: I am the key master.
[SPEAKER_05]: Not to boast or anything, but I can open a few doors myself.
[SPEAKER_04]: However...
[SPEAKER_04]: Probably the best place, we've talked about this, is if you take this lower wall on the garrison.
[SPEAKER_04]: The tower is right there and there's an entrance into it.
[SPEAKER_04]: If you can get through the first door, whether it be open or you can force it or open it, you'll have access to the rest of the keep.
[SPEAKER_04]: You can make it to the inner sanctum and see who is guarding there.
[SPEAKER_04]: If Fairwind is still alive, he should let you in.
[SPEAKER_04]: That's the most direct way to get to them.
[SPEAKER_04]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_02]: So, I vote we take the coastline, not directly on the coastline, of course.
[SPEAKER_02]: Gouge and I going forward and searching out for these tunnels.
[SPEAKER_02]: That's my vote.
[SPEAKER_02]: I mean, levitating is great, but even hobgoblins know they don't levitate.
[SPEAKER_01]: And that's going to stick out like a sore throat.
[SPEAKER_01]: I agree with one percent.
[SPEAKER_01]: I vote this route just because it is the quickest and
[SPEAKER_01]: That's the most direct route that I think...
[SPEAKER_04]: I have no idea how to go through the tunnels to get inside the helm.
[SPEAKER_01]: I'm just worried about Tzahagin and if those tunnels even lead to the helm or just a room full of hobgoblins feeding.
[SPEAKER_01]: So that's my only concern.
[SPEAKER_01]: I see what you mean.
[SPEAKER_02]: We'll put it to a vote then.
[SPEAKER_02]: But we do need to... Is the elf gonna have any say in this?
[SPEAKER_05]: Oh yeah, the elf will have a say in this.
[SPEAKER_05]: I'll go get him here in a second.
[SPEAKER_04]: Do you want to disturb Jude and bring him in?
[SPEAKER_01]: Yes.
[SPEAKER_01]: I mean, yeah, or I'm not going to wait until 3.
[SPEAKER_00]: Alright, I want to go with him when he goes to get him.
[SPEAKER_00]: Okay.
[SPEAKER_00]: You guys wait here.
[SPEAKER_01]: I want to find something to drink.
Get back!